[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
Guys, Grant and I are going
to be at a Mini Maker Faire.
It's at Electric Park in Thanksgiving Point,
which is in Lehi, Utah.
It's going to be going
down September 15th.
We're going to be bringing
some of our favorite projects.
We're going to have a stage show.
We'll have a craft table where
you can make your own Sky balls.
It's going to be awesome.
Check the link in the description
for 20% off of admission price,
which is only like $8 to start with.
So if you can make it out there,
would love to see you.
[Music]
YouTube user Ricky Alvarez
wanted to see what would happen
if we put a smoke grenade
inside of a watermelon.
We're pretty sure it would just
make smoke inside the watermelon,
and leak out wherever the hole is.
So we wanted to upgrade this
idea to something even cooler.
We want to turn the watermelon
into the smoke grenade.
So we've got all our chemicals
for making our smoke powder.
We're going to mix up a batch
in six different colors,
layer them inside the watermelon,
add a pull-tab fuse,
and see what happens.
The idea here is simple.
We've got a great recipe for making
smoke powder in several different colors.
We'll mix up a batch of each color,
layer them inside our hollow watermelon,
light it off, and see what the result is.
The first step is going to be mixing up
a whole bunch of our smoke powder base.
That has four different chemicals,
all of which are a white powder,
and we then go ahead
and add the colored powders later.
But we're not going to do that here.
We're going to take this up
to the Dome and light it off
because it's a much better area.
We're not bothering people with the smoke.
So let's mix up, I don't know about
that jar full of smoke powder base.
We'll take that up to the Dome,
mix up the individual colors,
and fill our watermelon.
[Music]
Once we've got all of our smoke
powder mixed up inside of a watermelon,
we're going to want to add one
of those little pull tab fuse igniters,
because those are by far the most fun.
So, we've got a book of matches,
we've got some fuse,
and I have this steel straw that I'm going
to use to sort of guide the fuse down
into the watermelon into the powder.
[Music]
We've got a watermelon,
we've got our smoke powder,
and we have our pull-tab fuse.
Let's head up to the Dome,
hollow this thing out,
fill it with smoke powder, and light it up.
Here we are out of the Dome, so now
it's time to hollow out this watermelon,
and fill it up with smoke powder.
[Music]
Not bad.
Our watermelon is carved out.
It's got holes added into it.
It's got a spot for our fuse straw.
Let's finish mixing up the
smoke powder and fill it up.
[Music]
One caveat I should explain
before we light this off.
All of the chemicals that we're
using for this are like 10 months old,
and I'm not entirely sure
if they go bad or not.
So we're hoping that this
ignites the same way as other
smoke stuff we've done.
But we don't know.
[Music]
Here we go.
A watermelon full of smoke
powder, and I mean like that is
a lot of smoke powder in there.
Here we go.
Pull tab.
[Music]
We have ignition.
So much ignition.
Uh...
That's amazing.
[Music]
Little piece of fuse flew out.
Holy cow.
That is a lot of smoke.
[Music]
Oh, it's working really well.
Remember how I was worried
that maybe it wasn't going to work.
I'm not worried anymore.
Yeah.
[Music]
It's getting more energetic.
I don't know how the lid has separated
from the rest of the watermelon.
I think the body of the watermelon
got so hot that it just kind
of contracted and curled down.
The lid just stayed up on top.
That right there is the remnants
of a whole lot of smoke powder.
Oh, that worked great!
There's like little bits
of every color that didn't quite burn.
We're just getting
plumes of different colors.
I love how divided up the colors are.
Like it's not just all swirling
together to make one gray mist.
You really seeing a bunch of different
colors coming out at different times.
When the smoke cleared, I half
expected this garage door to just
be completely multicolored,
like someone had
just graffitied all over it.
But amazingly, it didn't
really seem to do much.
That was the largest amount of
smoke powder I've ever set off at once,
and the effect was really, really cool.
There was so much smoke that was
so thick and so vibrantly colored.
I was honestly a little worried that it
wasn't going to work in transition colors.
I thought we might just get a grayish
brownish plume coming out the top,
but it did a really good job of just
going through the whole rainbow order.
I love how it turned out, and then
just the extra that I poured out has
just been going and it keeps finding
little bursts of more smoke to ignite.
Overall, very cool idea.
Ricky Alvarez, thank
you for your suggestion.
Check your YouTube inbox.
We'll be sending you 25 bucks.
Remember, if you've got
a fun idea for an experiment,
let us know down in the comments,
and if we like your idea, we'll send you $25.
Guys, that's not all,
there's more fun for you to see.
That little box up of the top will
transport you directly to our last video.
You should check that out.
The other box will show you what YouTube
thinks you need to be watching next,
and if you hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll be subscribed to our channel
so you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.